I think it is necessary to transcend the prevailing borders
Changing the rules of the game
I grew up in a farm
My childhood was wonderful
Because I grew up next to my father and worked in the field
One of the things I learned
The meaning of working throughout the day
I think the farmer can be described as an entrepreneur
So I wanted to become an entrepreneur
I decided to study computing for mobile devices
I met my partner at work
I liked jogging
We had the idea of ​​creating something in this area
We want to help people change their lives
Physical fitness affects all the activities we practice
So we left our jobs and founded Runtastic
The sport jogging feature connects you with the other person
So jogging with my daughter was wonderful
Do you want to continue?
Yes, we can
I was 40 years old when I started running
The whole thing began with a challenge
My daughter, Alexis in the jogging race recorded 10 km
I was very angry
I told her I would run 5 kilometers to show my support
She told me it was not so easy
But I accepted the challenge and ran 5 kilometers in full
In her first marathon
I achieved first place in Nashville
I used a Runtastic application to help me
In the marathon ran within 3 hours and 30 minutes and succeeded in it
I enjoyed encouraging my daughter to me
Every 30 minutes approx
I was running next to her
I know the distance I have made and what remains until the end
And since I started running
I have done all kinds of races
Currently I'm training for the second marathon
I learned from jogging that I could do a lot
I am proud to be her daughter
Which is why I continue running
And for her I would have stopped running
Alexis began to look for half-marathon races
I support her and ask her to determine where we will go
Let's run him together
We encouraged each other so we did not protest to anyone else
Evolution of my business
Much in previous years
Now it has more than 200,000 employees
And received 220 million downloads
We still aspire to much
After our partnership with Adidas
We want to move on to the next level
Technology gives us great ideas
Google Play was a great partner for us
Using Google Play technologies
We've been able to experiment with apps and re-experiment in an innovative and fast way
That's what we wanted to create a product
Great for users
It also helps us to innovate
It's great to see users develop their lifestyle
They are capable of achieving things they have never been able to achieve
Here is the opportunity to do so.